mornin with film courage the radio show
were here with the cosmonaut writer
director Nicholas aqua all the way from
Madrid Spain and he's here for afm and
we're actually here at AFI talking in
the private press room so I'm curious
Nicholas tell us what inspired the
cosmonaut well it's funny there was a
Spanish photographer like that ten years
ago he made a project he worked with a
lot of legends about lost cosmonauts
during the Soviet era there were a lot
of lanes that about cosmos going to
space and never coming back or die in
his face and he made the project about
this and then he made a lot of fake
pictures about himself as a cosmonaut
that was erased from pictures and things
like that and that was the main
inspiration for the project I mean this
idea of a cosmonaut getting lost in
space and his spaceship coming back
empty okay no one inside and people
finding the spaceship empty this was the
main inspiration
okay so now I understand you have not
actually shot the movie yet you'll shoot
it in the spring of next year okay okay
and now you're using crowdfunding and I
think you've already raised some funds
and you're going to use more crowd
funding through maybe Kickstarter or
some other channels that's right we've
been with the with the crowdfunding
campaign for almost a year and we'd
build a community of 2,300 producers
bought something in our online store we
have we've done it will on online store
and that's the way they help us with the
movie and now we're gonna make another
campaigns at Kickstarter or something
like that and what we're also looking
for money from other sources pretty
money and sponsors private investor
movie things like that that's it and so
what are some of the incentives for some
of the people that are participating in
the crowdfunding what what do they get a
t-shirt DVD yeah well that's that
usually the crowdfunding campaigns work
with birds I mean the more money put the
better things you get but we wanted to
make it like easier um or rewarding so
what we thought was to build this online
store so what you're doing in the air is
not donating not like helping but buying
things actual things if you want to be
sure you buy if you want a book if you
want something very cool related with
the movie Soviet spin or whatever you
buy it so in the end if whatever happens
and we don't make the movie or whatever
or I mean no one can complain because
there they are helping us buy anything
from the store that they receive and we
wanted people to really receive
something physical at home to make that
connection between them and the movie
through physical merchandised so they
can buy a lot of very cool stuff
related to the movie like get t-shirts
if the book that inspired the movie and
one of my favorites is this one were in
the 60s the United States spent like two
million dollars to develop a pen that
work in space under water with no
gravity backwards and all that Russians
use a pencil so we are setting service
solution that is one of the items we
have a lot of time so Nicholas I want to
dissect the crowdfunding model that
you're working on a little bit because
you didn't go with Kickstarter and
IndieGoGo or piracy those are all great
sites but um I think you tried to go
with IndieGoGo yeah in the beginning I
think that was even with this was a
short film I was very beginning we try
it IndieGoGo but they weren't open to
international projects so we weren't
able to and so we build our own blog
platform but we build an online store
where you can just buy merchandise and
become producer from three dollars you
can receive it producer certificate and
a few limited creates an and enter for
the contest for a cosmonaut soup real
cosmic suit and well then they came back
to ask to to ask us to put the project
on IndieGoGo but Roman with already
built the platform and we are in very
good relationships with them hoes
slabber up and all the guys and it's the
same with Kickstarter I mean now we are
going to be able to play there but it's
difficult because they are not open to
international project so you need an
account in the States and I know a lot
of people that wants to to use
Kickstarter but they can actually right
now I think it was a good idea to be on
Iran because it worked better I mean in
indigo valero like hundreds of projects
and it
it would have been difficult to be there
with a presence so because you didn't
use IndieGoGo or Kickstarter how did you
get the word out about your crowdfunding
campaign oh that was funny we have
absolutely no money because it was a
very independent project so what we did
was to contact the main the most
important blocks in Spain about
technology about movies about things
related to what we were doing and they
loved it so the first week we learnt the
project mccroskey arrows which is the
most-read blog in Spain gave us a post
and like I don't know 100,000 people
came to the side it was crazy and from
there a lot of all the bluffs began to
talk about us and from there internet
media and once the intermediate started
to talk about this thing the whole I
mean in Spain with a beer in all the
media all televisions all newspapers or
radius so when they saw it in the
internet they decided to interview US
work work spreading the interim people
love the prior tell their friends and
that was the idea interesting and how is
the money actually getting to you as a
through paypal yeah right now is to
people that has been difficult because
in Spain not many people use it and we
are now trying to be more international
and to get people from all around the
world but on our main community was
built in Spain and they don't use people
as much as we wanted to so we have tried
to to we are now actually trying to make
another payment options like to credit
card or SMS or things like that it's
important to means the way they are able
to people is able to pay will give you
more opportunities most options you have